there are four seasons each year
rafael gets a haircut two times each
season
one at arlo's barber shop and the other
at awesome snips
which choices represent the number of
haircuts raphael will get this year and
they've even made a diagram for us right
over here so they tell us there's four
seasons in the year spring summer autumn
winter and then each season raphael gets
two haircuts he gets one at arlo's and
one at awesome snips so in spring this
is the one that he gets at arlo's this
is the one that he gets at awesome snips
at summer this is one he gets at arlo's
this is the one that he gets at awesome
snips autumn this is the one he gets at
heart gets at arlo's this is the one
that awesome snips at winter this is the
one at arlo's this is the one at awesome
snips
so they ask us
which choices represent the number of
haircuts raphael will get this year
well one way to think about it is
in spring he will get two haircuts then
in summer he's going to get another two
haircuts in autumn he's going to get
another two haircuts and then in winter
he's going to get another two haircuts
so he's going to get two
in spring plus two in summer plus two in
autumn plus two in winter which is going
to be equal to eight haircuts so which
of these represent eight
let's see two plus two that's not eight
four plus four plus four plus four
that's not eight that's sixteen two plus
two is four four plus four is eight plus
four is twelve plus four is sixteen
that's not eight
four plus four
that is equal to eight that is the
number of haircuts raphael is going to
get this year so we can check that one
two plus two plus two plus two that's
exactly what we wrote here and it is
eight
so that is equal to the number of
haircuts he's gonna get this year
and then two plus four well that's not
equal to eight that's six so that's not
right so these are the two that
represent the number of haircuts raphael
will get this year